how are you feeling today as opposed to
last Monday when I talk to you the
juices continue to flow I think last
night's 2 episodes really took me back
to the center of 90s really late 80s and
early 90s basketball because the
feelings and you could see the raw
emotion on MJ's face in talking about
Isiah and the bad boys and the Pistons
for those people who didn't understand
that he's correct back then you played
especially in your division you played
each other six times three at home three
on the road so you built up a lot of
disdain and dislike towards certain
teams and Detroit was one of those teams
but I will say this and I know looking
at the videos and the images of taking
him out the air a lot of teams were like
that the Knicks were like that Miami was
like that Milwaukee was like this
Celtics were like that there was a lot
of teams that played a very physical
presence especially in the Eastern
Conference because we only played the
Eastern Conference teams twice but
especially in the East that was the
brand of basketball but you could see on
his face that MJ is still living with it
and I I agree with them because you know
we had to face him six times and go
against that bad boy defense but it was
you couldn't be a punk you couldn't be a
punk and I remember you know going
against you know Dumars and what do you
mean a punk you not back down not back
down and you couldn't just settle see
they wanted you to settle they didn't
think you could the were you up for the
punishment so Joe would tell me because
he was like the gentle guy on that team
so and he got it we guarded one another
he's like reg I'm just telling you if
you beat me
and you get into the paint you know
what's going to happen well I know
what's going to happen we want me to do
sit out here and just continue to shoot
I just couldn't sit out here and shoot
jump shots so you had to take the
punishment that's just how it was right
you couldn't be a punk
you had to get in there and take it so
what you get up and you know you move on
that style though like the Pistons lead
ugly yeah but but the Pistons didn't
care if you like them or not like they
wanted you to be I would if I'm a piston
now if I'm Isaiah Bill Laimbeer I like
that Michael Jordan's still mad yeah I
mean that's that's why you were playing
you wanted to rent space in somebody's
head you know but I then you turn around
and you go did Michael rent space in
their heads too because then you don't
you walk off the floor and you're not
even going to acknowledge Jordan you're
just feeding the beast if you do that
like I'd rather be nice with Mike then
if I'm gonna I'm gonna tug on superman's
cape it ain't going well it's not going
to go well from this point on well if
your lamb beer Mahorn Isaiah to a
certain degree you know job well done
because you're absolutely right they did
not care at the time and they're right
it was Larry it was magic the next was
Michael and all those three teams I just
mentioned played a beautiful brand of
basketball you know you had Showtime
fast-break
the beautiful passes by magic and
finishes by worthy and cream and you had
the beautiful you know stroke of Larry
legend and they played well as a team
and the championships and you had
Michael who was you know five to six
feet above everyone else floating on air
and then you had the bad boys right who
didn't care who played a physical style
of basketball but guess what it worked
and that model in brand went to New York
for Pat Riley it went to Miami with Pat
Riley
so that branded basketball was around
for a while there was a niche for it and
teams tried to adopt that and now you
see in today's games how they have gone
away from that and it's everything is
more so catered toward
the office now they would much rather
see you score 100 1520 125 points as
opposed to the Pistons brand of
basketball when it was right oh it was
so bad do you think that Michael
single-handedly said I don't want Isiah
on the dream team yes and I know you
know look let me just say this Isiah
Thomas should have been on that 92 dream
team and people girls I will who you
would you have taken off John Stockton
our Clyde Drexler well one of those two
guys Christian Laettner
one of those three guys Isiah Thomas
should have been on that team because of
what he had done in the league his
stature he had won two championships he
should have been on their team do you
know for a fact that Mike was the reason
why Isiah didn't make the dream team I
wouldn't say for a fact but I think it
is the unwritten rule that people talk
about yeah I wouldn't say it's MJ alone
but how it might get this past Chuck
Daly who was I say his coach who coached
the dream team that's what I don't
understand we're nothing to do with
Chuck Daly because at the time this was
Commissioner Stern putting this team
together but do you think the
Commissioner said do you think he said
Mike I want you on the dream team and
Mike said to the Commissioner I will but
these are the guys I want this is the
guy I don't want no I wouldn't say he
said these are the guys I want I believe
MJ probably said okay I'll do it
but Isaiah cannot be on this team I
didn't he didn't like make the roster
but he made sure someone wasn't on the
rock but what bothers people or bothered
people about Isiah Thomas because you
you know he's so cute a smile cute
little teddy bear he was a little in
stature but he was you talk about the
bad boys he might have been the meanest
and toughest of the bad boys but you
didn't think about that because of the
smile and he had one you know a
championship at IU under Bobby Knight
and he formed that team
he formed them into that that tough take
him out the air but it was Lam beer and
bullhorn and Buddha and Rodman and John
Salley they they took all the hits you
know because they were the bad boys but
the conduct you was conducting all of
that behind the scenes talking to Reggie
Miller the Hall of Famer Turner Sports
NBA analyst I try to tell people how
great Rodman was with the Pistons and I
just you know when he was with the Bulls
he became a little more one-dimensional
where he was just rebound he wasn't the
great defender he was in Detroit he he
took pride in guarding bird or James
Worthy and he just was a pogo stick he
just ran all day but can you imagine a
coach who says to his player you can go
to Vegas for a couple of days in season
yeah and and they gave him his his
blessings to go there so he could shack
up with Carmen Electra look what do you
see from the that image in the videos
that could not be done today because of
camera phones smartphones because of
social media if you look at the footage
there are no cameras going off there are
no people aren't holding cell phones up
when he's on stage and his shirt is off
you could do those I mean it's a human
GPS nowadays your phone so you know you
could track everyone's movement that
could not happen in in today's era of
because of social media but you know I
go to tell people think about if you're
Phil Jackson and the Bulls you have
arguably three of the best on ball
perimeter defenders in the game on one
team MJ Scottie and Dennis so if those
guys played in today's games where you
switch everything every pick-and-roll
that's like lockdown City and I try to
tell people people like but he didn't
score like what did he do well he did -
the scoring
the rebounding the positioning and all
the toughness you know I don't think
I've told the story before when Michael
was filming Space Jam they built the
Jordan dome for him so he could work out
and he would film all day you know
six o'clock call time and he would be
done like around 6:00 p.m. seven o'clock
and then we would go up and actually it
was the best runs ever so they called it
the Jordan dome and all the top ballers
came up on the Warner Brothers lot
invitation-only
imitate someone invitation I mean
Michael didn't say who he wanted but it
was all the top players so you had you
know Eddie Jones at the time
Juwan Howard guys being bleep magic came
through once or twice but it was
unbelievably fraf but it was nothing
hard fouls and this is at the time where
they were thinking about signing Rodman
and my good friend and my teammate at
UCLA Jack Haley who had been Robins
babysitter in San Antonio and then in
Chicago it was close to them signing him
and other than MJ during those runs
Rodman I mean I had prayed again so
obviously when he was in Detroit and San
Antonio was phenomenal and usually in
pickup games Dan you know this it's all
about scoring and you know oleh defense
so what was he going to bring in a
pickup game phenomenal phenomenal and
the little exercise that he did last
night about tracking the rebounds and he
could tell the arcs and the rotations
it's absolutely 100% true the Inc thinks
this young that that dude had was
unbelievable yeah he's he's a
fascinating guy just can't imagine if
you go imagine somebody nowadays going
hey I can I go to Vegas free like
remember when Johnny Manziel they had a
weekend off and he went to Vegas I mean
you know people went crazy over that but
with
Enes I think Phil's geniuses he knew how
to treat everybody as an individual a
lot of coaches treat everybody
collectively and I think Phil was able
to look at you individually and say this
is what you need that's different from
what he needs and another fascinating
look what's great about this doc is the
in-game adjustment that the great
players make the interaction that MJ had
with Rodman about you know a particular
switch when oak is coming behind me the
great ones know how to adapt on the fly
because everyone has a game plan coming
into a game and then you know like Mike
Tyson said once you get punched in the
mouth you got to be able to adapt those
guys were able to adapt on the fly to
any situation and just to hear the
talking I mean that's what I've missed
probably the most in watching this thing
because it's it's those those minor
adjustments as teammates and his
brothers that you make that makes the
difference routine you know being a
champion and you know being a runner-up
and that'll is what's fascinating to see
I know we get into this discussion it's
like who's the greatest of all time and
then we go back and forth with that but
when you start to look at great teams we
look at it's really the generation in
which they played in you know the
Celtics of the 60s wouldn't come
anywhere near a team now you know the
Bulls in the 90s though it feels like
they could play physical if they had to
they could run if they needed to they
could play great defense if they needed
to they would have adapted to become
better 3-point shooters because the game
would have called for that and if I took
Golden State with Durant and Steph and
clay and put them back in the 90s you
know so if I do it the other way around
I put Jordan's Bulls you know now
against Golden State and I take Golden
State now and put them back with the
Bulls how do you think that that fares
I think the Bulls would have been
unbelievable in today's generation so we
just mentioned about them being able to
switch everything which they do in
today's game and you have three of the
best on ball perimeter defenders with
beat Golden State with drin yes the
seven games here but here's my here's my
thing if you put that Golden State team
in the 90s the question is going to be
because back then you could hold you
could hit you saw the physical play yeah
it's just going to be able to hold up to
that right i Katie I believe could
Durant yes possibly clay is step now I
know Steph would be able to adapt
because we all would have to but you get
to hold back then you get to be in the
clinches you get to take people out the
air is he able to take that punishment
could you imagine if the Bron and KD
took that punishment that MJ and a lot
of us had to take in the 90s I just
wonder how they would I would love to
see that
good now that's a flagrant foul and
possibly a five game suspension well but
you wouldn't be expecting those calls
it's if I if I say LeBron is the same
size as Karl Malone with a better hand
so Karl could handle it I'm looking at
LeBron if he doesn't know hey wait am I
supposed to get those calls or they they
they would give me those calls in
another era if he knows only what he's
playing I think LeBron would be he would
be great come on LeBron could've played
60 in any air yeah yeah LeBron in any
era yeah some players you're wondering
could they play in any era but would you
take the 20 you could play Katie could
play in any era if I took Kobe and Shaq
versus the Golden State Warriors with
Durant that's an unbelievable matchup
because no one had an answer for Shaq
and those four those first three
championship no one had an answer for
Shaq I don't know what Chicago would
have done but if I pan if I put time
against Golden State will be an MJ that
would have been and you know I still
give the edge to MJ but Kobe would have
kept him honest and you got Pippen who's
gonna cover who's gonna match with him
you got Rodman
what if I put Shaq and Kobe versus
Golden State with Durant Steph clay okay
now what are you playing in today's
rules or today's rule today's rules you
don't have a mess people Shaq was a B
man you never asked for that dude man
but you don't think JaVale McGee is
gonna be able to stop no no but you
think that Shaq Kobe versus the Bulls
they would give them a better run than
the Golden State Warriors with Durant
Steph and klay I do because of of Shaq
and Kobe is gonna go my him and Mike are
gonna go maybe not toe to toe but it's
gonna be pretty close he would keep him
honest yes both ends of the floor hey
before I let you go NBA talking about
opening up camps here May first opening
up facilities what do you what do you
think what kind of time frame we looking
at well if they open up practice
facilities that means guys can go in and
actually get workouts in it's probably
going to take most players anywhere from
two and a half to three weeks to get in
some type of shape I mean I think you're
looking at mid June again if you're
gonna resume basketball we're talking
about mid June to late June of getting
in be a basketball back again I would
with no fans though yeah I don't see
that happening but shouldn't you already
be in shape how much how out of shape
can you be being safe how are they being
safe there
they've been at home what on a treadmill
there's home gyms
that's not basketball shape what's not
with different they're not gonna have a
beer gut
no but conditioning is going to take a
while to get your legs back it's gonna
take a while do you believe that Steph
Curry doesn't have a basketball hoop at
his house I believe he does not have a
basketball hoop at his house and then
amazing know most players don't have an
indoor court well no
even an outdoor you got it do you have
an outdoor court I do okay let's shoot
in outdoors and doing drills outdoors is
a lot different than doing drilled in
door who's the second best shooter in
your neighborhood I would say all Pierce
is around here somewhere I would say
Paul Pierce
Paul Pierce is around here somewhere if
I would say no I would say Paul George
Paul George okay
Paul George Paul George so I would be
the third best shooter if I lived it
would be you would be the third best
shooter in calabasas I baby the tough
courts of Calabasas high all right we're
gonna check in with you when when your
episode do is your episode eight or nine
you know it's one of those two for what
I was in here I'd find out from our good
friend Gail when when you you get
featured here in the documentary again I
have no idea how they know I guess how
they frame this nor do I care like what
he said about Isaiah being a a-hole yeah
I might be in that same vein so I
apologize I'm really a nice guy but not
on the court I know you were that's why
you became a hall-of-famer
all right reg thanks bud talk to you
soon yeah all the best all right that's
Reggie Aloysius Miller